In this video,
we'll look at some example of
results we can get using unsupervised
pre-training.
So we saw the procedure
funds provide speed training.
What we first do is that we initialize
each layer from the first hidden layer to
the last hidden layer by
training a, uh, what we call it,
greedy modules or either an
rpm or an auto encoder, uh,
on a dataset that was generated by
transforming the input data into the
representation of their
previous, uh, they didn't layer.
And then we use the weights and the biases
found for that hidden there that was
trained using an RBM when a tone
corridor as the initial value for the
parameters of that hidden layer in our
deep neural network they want to use for
classification.
And then we initialize randomly the
last part of the neural network,
the output layer, and then we, uh,
training using regular back pro,
which is referred to as fine to me.
So what we'll see is a few results on a
training deep neural networks on deep,
uh, on different, uh, image
classification problems.
So these were generated by
myself and my colleagues, uh,
to get an idea of the performance of,
of uh,
deep neural networks in different settings
with different p training algorithms
and different configurations
are architectures of the
neural networks and so on.
So we had a bunch of variations on DM,
this data set where we added rotations.
We see here characters with
different amounts of rotation.
The incorporation of a random background
or background extracted from a,
an actual image,
uh,
taken from the web and a combination
of a rotation and some background.
I also had another classification problem,
uh,
visual classification problem where we
have a rectangle in some image and we
have to say whether it's taller or
wider when, since this would be a,
a wide rectangle and this
would be a tall rectangle.
So these would be two different classes
and this would be binary classification
problem.
And then the harder version of that
problem where the rectangle correspond not
to a set of black and white pixels,
but instead of different,
uh,
so there's a background and then there's
a patch corresponding to the rectangle
in question, which was extracted
from a different image.
And then we have another binary
classification problem and we have to say
whether the shape in the image is
convex to, for instance, in this case,
this is not convex because I can draw
a line between say that white pixel and
that white pixel here and this line goes
over a black pixels so it doesn't stay
in the white shape in the image.
And whereas this would be convex shape.
So these would be the two classes for
this classification problem as well.
We trained deep neural networks on these
different data sets and looked at the
result and see what kind of
conclusions we could make out of them.
Okay. In this first experiments, uh, we'll
look at the impact of initialization.
So we considered the deep neural
network without pre-training. Uh,
another one with pre-training using
irregular auto encoder or portraying using
the RBM.
And in each case we considered a depth.
So number of hidden layers
of one, two, three and four.
So I guess this would be one would be,
wouldn't be very deep, but of course two,
three and four would be
considered the neural network.
And then we performed
experiment on amnesty,
the original feminist but a
which we referred to as small a.
So we just essentially reduced
the size of the training sets, uh,
but it's essentially original m this
digits as extracted from the original
Dataset.
And we compared with a,
and also did experiment with the
rotation variation that we generated.
So there are are three
different conclusions we can
draw from these experiments.
The first thing is that a deep
neural network actually helps.
So in all cases the performance without a,
Oh sorry.
It actually pre-training helps. That's
the first conclusion. So if, uh,
we don't use any portraying a four m,
the smaller we get about 4% performance.
If we use auto encoder for training,
we're more at 3.3% a error.
And then with RBM you
get even better at 2.7.
And then a similar conclusion for say
a the rotation where we get better and
better performance,
better performance in general and for
use be training either doing quarter in
RBM.
The other conclusion we can draw is
that pre training also helps training
success, uh, with success.
A deeper networks,
indeed the deepest neural
network. Well, I guess the, um,
the shallow is neural network with a
performance that's as good as the best
performance we can get
in this case would be 4%.
So this is statistically
undistinguishable from these two results.
If with two or three hidden
layers in this case, however, uh,
training to hidden,
there's is better than just one.
And similarly here for m this small
using either autoencoder quarter and RBM
portraying.
So we see that we've been able to train
with success in their own network that
had one more hidden layer using their
unsupervised speed training procedure.
And we actually get the same conclusion
on this rotation where the best we could
do is to hidden layers here.
And then three with retraining,
either with auto encoder on RBM.
And then the third
conclusion is, um, that,
uh,
by going from a somewhat simple problem,
the original Lemonis
problem to a harder problem,
which is to classify rotated digits,
the best performance we
obtain was actually a,
with a more with a deeper neural
network for them rotation problem.
Then for the original end,
this problem. So in the,
we went from one hidden layer to to
hidden there as our best result from two
hidden layer two 300 in there as our best
result here and two to three also with
the RBM be training. So this, uh,
sort of confirms our intuition that for
more complicated problems we should have
more success and get a better result
using a deeper neural network.
When we went from m this small,
do you have this rotation using one
more hidden layer actually helped.
Okay. So this sort of justifies even
more the use of deep neural networks
and these experiment from
another paper by these guys here.
Uh, they did experiment with one, two,
or three hidden layers with, uh,
either RBM pre-training or a,
in this case they use de
noising autoencoder pre-training
or no pre training at
all. So the NOPA training
would be the black line.
And what they did is that the varied
the number of hidden units in the neural
network and saw with just one
or two or three hidden layers,
uh, what was the progression
of the performance on a,
the test set performance
in terms of generalization.
And what we see is that if the
neural network has little capacity,
so a few hidden units, um,
then pre-training doesn't help.
We get better test error without
retraining then with training.
But as we increase the capacity,
eventually these two set of lines cross
and now without retraining over fits.
So it has a, uh, worse test
error then with be training.
And we get the same shape either with,
uh,
two hidden layers or three hidden.
There's so that confirms that really we're
getting a preacher tiny acts as their
regular riser because if the neural
networks deep or not has few parameters,
so little capacity, then, um,
much like any regularization
will we expect to see is, uh,
under fitting a, so less, uh,
so worst result in terms of test Eric
was that as we increase the capacity,
then the better regularized model
starts doing better. And in this case,
the better regularized model correspond
to the neural networks with a free
training
here,
here.
Okay.
So again,
this confirms our intuition that we can
think of retraining on surprise speed
training as a rigger riser. It will,
uh, over fit less with large capacity,
but it will lead to under
fitting with small capacity.
This other experiments is a one
where we try to see what was the best
architecture, uh, to use in a deep neural
network with three hidden layers. So,
uh,
if we have three hidden layers,
we have to choose the number of
hidden units and each hidden there,
that can be a bit cumbersome
and annoying to do. Uh,
so here we considered
three types of choices.
One where we would as we go deeper,
decreased the number of hitting
it so they keep decrease.
The width of the hidden there. So
decreasing with would be a hidden there,
kind of like this,
like this movie.
And the constant would be the same
number of heating units each in there.
And then increasing would be
more and more hidden units as we,
uh, get closer to the output
layer. Okay. So these,
this is what these three set
of three lines mean here.
And then we considered the
performance for different number,
total number of hidden units
and the neural networks.
And uh, and here we have the
performance either on em,
this small or an end,
this rotation.
And here we have a
performance for each column,
either with RBM free training
or Toyland quarter paternity.
And the general trend seems to be that
using the same number of hidden units, uh,
so constant with, uh, tends
to do, uh, either, uh,
at least as well or better
than other options. Um,
so normally we see that the often the
confidence intervals between the different
performances overlap with,
uh, the constant with and,
uh, or it's actually doing a better
say for instance in this case.
So this is kind of reassuring. It
means that perhaps we can just, uh, uh,
at least in our first experiments,
concentrate on neural networks with the
same number of heating units and just
try different number of hidden
units for each, uh, hidden there.
And he rubbed the performance on all
of the data sets I mentioned before.
So that just in this rotation
and, uh, and this, uh,
small for either a Svm,
so I'm not going to describe what it is,
but it's a,
a very popular type of
classifier and machine learning.
And here we're using the colonel
Verint within RBF kernel.
And here we have the
results with pre-training,
with stacked auto encoders rbms
or the nosing two quarters.
And we always use three hidden layers.
So,
first thing we see is that deep
neural networks, either the A,
what I call DBN here with is really
just a stack of rbms for p training or,
uh,
stacking the nosing twin quarters
tend to do better than using an SBM,
which is,
uh,
which correspond to a very good
but shallow class classifier.
And so not a deep classifier.
Um, we see also that, uh,
auto encoders tend to perform less well
than either rbms or the noisy motor in
quarters and rbms they
dinos and auto encoders, uh,
tend to do about as well.
So Tom,
sometimes the free training that RBM
works better than de noising and sometimes
it's the other way around.
Um, and so in practicing,
we do observe that they tend to be
somewhat equivalent than in terms of the
performance, but very
on, on various dataset.
It might be that one will work
better than the other. So, um,
so they're both really good
reasonable options for a pre training,
whereas regular auto
encoders, uh, might not, uh,
is not worthwhile compared say to
just de noising or two in quarters.
So this confirms what we discussed before,
that the nausea and auto encoders are
really a way of improving on the regular
auto in quarter. All right?
So that ends our examples. So,
uh, we see that unsupervised
training is helpful.
It helps in terms of
regularizing the model,
and it also allows us for more complicated
task to get better performance with a
deeper neural networks.